today's topic so we got this youtuber on
this platform who uh essentially had
this video and it kind of went viral so
let's play it and you guys aren't aware
of the backstory the backstory is kind
of simple um
she takes her dog to get diagnosed finds
out the dog has cancer they get back in
the car they start to film the video for
their lifestyle channel because that's
what she is she's a youtube lifestyle
creator and she's doing this video with
her son the son's visibly crying and
this is what happens pray for us we
appreciate it i love you guys
okay so the reason why the handle goes
over the camera is because basically she
was done she was telling the editor cut
from here use what's before come here
come closer
act like you're crying
i am crying
like this
excuse me
okay so
at one point the kid says no i'm really
crying and she says cold just pose and
there's a disconnect there
between the mother who should be
consoling her child and the mother or
the youtuber who's concerned with making
content she prioritized being a youtuber
and an influencer over being present for
her child who's going through something
traumatic and instead of
listening to that she's more concerned
with how it's supposed to look to the
outward
world so imagine how that goes into the
kid's mind where his pain is fetishized
or turned into entertainment for other
people his moment of because apparently
the kid the dog has got cancer which is
a pretty hard thing i imagine for a
child or any person here that's already
the first thing uh second thing i'm
surprised that you this is even allowed
on youtube this is the kind of stuff
that should get you deleted we talk
about child exploitation you know it's
not just kids in sweatshops you know if
you monetize your kids and you push them
into things that aren't good for their
mental health because it plays you money
that should be an issue same way some
people force their kids into acting okay
and it [ __ ] those kids up that should
be an issue oftentimes we look to
foreign countries and we talk about oh
they don't treat those kids well it
happens here sometimes too and at very
high levels of society so this to me is
quite concerning
do i just put one hand up like this
no go like this
but let them see your mouth
let them see your mouth
look at me look at me look at me
look at me look at me
i know look at me look at me
the kids say i'm really crying she's
just saying look at me look at me look
at me and again that's again that
self-centered nature that me me me me
attitude where people ugh you can tell
this is not a mother it's a [ __ ] with a
kid ain't that what you said yeah so
what is this hot supply go ahead was it
say the line
go ahead take your line why you got all
these memories man stop it
if you're 25 you're not a milf you're
just a [ __ ] with a kid
oh man that was the whole quote that's
what i said it was 2012 it's not my life
i was young then you know i was not
young
all right but yeah it's a difference you
know it's just a difference there's some
parent that's and that's what i was
saying basically you know
there's some people that want kids and
some people that are parents she wanted
kids as an accessory that's what she's
using the kids for hmm
i can't
take anybody
that cries on cam and keeps filming
seriously
i can't because i'm thinking about that
and some of y'all maybe
you're
like it's real and everything and stuff
when you cut a moment they still want to
say your story
but
i'm not if i cry i'm not going to film
myself
i'm not filming myself to pull that [ __ ]
that's very big to me that's just you
don't cry and po
well some people they have moments it
happens i'm not saying no and yes that
that's that's exactly what i said
actually
uh i said that i said there are some
people that's real yeah yeah but you're
saying if you see someone crying on
camera that's not no you you just took a
part of what i said
but yeah there are some people that do
cry for real and you know they're having
a moment they're they do i understand
that but there's some other people that
keep on full and you know it's it's how
do you tell the difference
you you can't okay and that's the reason
why i'm like whenever i see someone
crying i don't watch a video what i see
whether it's a jimmy kimmel whenever
it's whatever if you're just like uh
i have a problem with that because of
that it tainted that for me because i
know there are some people like they're
going to put their theirs
especially when you do lifestyle and you
expose your life and i know that all
that you expose is not exactly that
and then you're just gonna oppose that
you see someone crying i see you trying
to make content out of your your sorrow
out of your your sadness and i'm not
having it it's really just that i know
what you're saying my heart like dropped
i rewatched the footage and i cannot
believe i rewatched it and you guys are
completely right 100 million percent
right and i so hope you know that i'm
genuine about that hey listen there's a
cost when you turn your family into
content
you are giving a piece of yourself to
the world and the world has input on
that but then also
it's like being observed changes the
subject
it changes the way you behave even for
us it changes the way we behave by being
online on this platform when i'm walking
through a town when i'm engaging with
people i already have to have an air of
suspicion because a lot of people come
in with weird intentions it kind of
[ __ ] with your head a little bit
when you bring your family you invite
them into that world you turn them into
content for other people and it makes
you money but you bring them in to now
having to deal with what it means to be
viewed through that lens and to be
changed by folks who are observing you
and so that's why i'm really reluctant
to post anything with my siblings
anymore is because i've seen how it
affects folks and
i don't want that for them and they
don't want that for themselves right so
i already have a problem with people
bringing their families into this stuff
if the families don't fully understand
what it is that they're getting into and
people don't really walk them through
that
but then to bring your kids who don't
have the maturity level to make their
own decisions and who are your
responsibility
for you to not care for their health and
their mental well-being first
and prioritizing content
there's a there's a disconnect there
this child
is your responsibility you have to care
and protect them why is it that when the
internet's backlash comes that's the
only time you start to consider you've
been receiving negative comments
probably your entire youtube career i
know because every youtuber goes to it
you want to bring your child into that
so casually
that's why i'm not a fan a lot of these
lifestyle channels especially the family
ones they're very sus to me yup
very sus yup
and oftentimes even the ones that do
well have to get a child psychologist
and all this other stuff just to
maintain people's men
what
at a time when kids should be at the
playground hanging out with friends and
join themselves they're concerned with
social media following a lot of time the
kids should be kids
you know so you're not letting kids be
kids yeah it's crazy
that's just some of the things that i
wanted to bring up
any thoughts
except her yeah
a lot it's just great
even people that are not into social
media is a weird [ __ ] spot yeah
people want to you know there's people
that right now that are coming into age
of maturity that are suing their parents
because of the pictures that they posted
without their consent
and it's gonna happen more and more
you're gonna have more kids growing up
and be like i didn't consent to this i
couldn't consent to this i was a kid and
you post my just my
um
all my life out there
people got pictures and [ __ ] i go to
school i get roasted on baby pictures
and [ __ ] cause you post all of that on
the internet
because you wanna i know man it's cringe
to me
yeah it's cringe it's weird it's
irresponsible yeah it's really
irresponsible and it's dangerous to your
kid
it's really it's not good for them so
yeah guys i understand making content is
great making money is fantastic but if
it comes at the expense of your child's
mental well-being you have to ask
yourself what does that say about you as
a person is it worth it shout out to the
editor who was didn't even bother
cutting that [ __ ] i said yo man [ __ ]
this [ __ ] i'm gonna put the whole thing
in there and shout out to the woman for
being such a potato that she uploaded
without watching it she just trusted her
editor i mean i know my dad for years i
still don't trust that [ __ ] i'll
be watching reviewing everything send it
to me [ __ ]
you don't upload nothing
king kong ain't got [ __ ] on me i'm not
gonna end up on the line i'm gonna put a
case on you i'm gonna put a case on you
i'ma put a case on you
good movie oh you're doing the
great movie that movie was this [ __ ] i
recently watched you doing this [ __ ] to
me
to me
oh that's good denzel's a man i better
have all you [ __ ] swimming in pelican
bank
guys he's holding his back with a jack
on the side of the truck because he got
shut in the butt [ __ ] yeah that movie
hard you shot me [ __ ] ah you
shot me in my ass
you shot me at my ass
for all the people who never watched the
movie it's really weird for everyone who
wants to be like my [ __ ]
my [ __ ]
we thought that was weed nah that's pcp
angel dust
yo
that white powder that move that movie
is amazing great movie shout out the man
uh denzel washington that's it for us
today let us know what you guys think in
the comments below how do you guys feel
about this
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
buddy
[Music]